the sushi science show clips
um I think that's like yeah speaking
more about
um memory and just like intelligence in
general
um and how like intelligence can be seen
I guess like at different levels
um and how you don't have to have like a
brain and a in a multicellularity to
have intelligence because you had an
interesting study that came out a couple
of years ago maybe uh where you have
something called cenobots but you just
took some some towels and you uh I mean
you're probably gonna explain a better
than I can but you were able to sort of
get it to do different behaviors and to
forms of intelligence I was just
wondering if you could explain a bit
better than I have about that yeah so so
there's two there's two interesting
pieces there um one one piece has to do
with intelligence and then and then uh
more broadly and then I'll talk about
the xenobots um I wanna I wanna start
with the intelligence part because I I
haven't specifically made any claims
about
um what kind of intelligence the
xenobots have that's still very much
gender investigation but I want to I
want to say something about intelligence
first
um
to me here's here's a proposed and there
are many but here's a proposed
definition of intelligence and I I
intelligence I think is uh I like
William James's intelligence it's a
definition of intelligence which is the
ability to get to the same goal by
different means so I think that's very
powerful and well I would put two twists
on that I would say one is yes and that
goal can be stated in many different
problem spaces it's not just physical
space but it might be more for space it
might be transcriptional space it might
be
um you know linguistic space in the case
of of advanced uh you know humans and
whatnot uh transcript um transcriptional
space physiological space and your
degree of intelligence is the competency
with which you pursue the goals that you
pursue in your sort of cognitive
sophistication is the size of the goals
you're able to pursue literally this the
size in that space so if you can only if
if what stresses you out is being far
from your goal of having the right local
sugar concentration you're probably a
bacterium if what if if on the other
hand you're able to pursue a goal about
the size of a human arm you're probably
a collection of cells making an arm if
your goal is
um you know a particular quality of the
Earth's financial markets and and you
know peace among men you're probably a
human that you can con you can even work
towards you can represent a goal of that
size right maybe maybe one that's not
going to be done in your lifetime and
that's an amazing thing that humans can
do so so so I have a very uh functional
generic view of intelligence I I don't
think it matters What You're Made Of how
you got here being involved design I
don't think any of that matters what
matters is are you a system that uh can
pursue different types of different
scales of goals and how how competently
do you pursue them to get caught in
local Minima do you have um any kind of
uh delayed gratification so you can go
around boundaries to get where you need
to be that kind of stuff
so the reason that the reason that I
think it's important to do that is
people people often have these binary
categories which I think are completely
false and and really hold back progress
people will say things like
I and maybe some apes and maybe my dog
and maybe an octopus and people fight
about that uh we are true intelligences
this other stuff well that's just
physics that's just a metaphor I mean I
can see the mechanisms you know the
aplesia has this and that mechanism for
you know habituation and that's just
chemistry and physics I have real
intelligence this is of course uh
impossible now that we we know about
Evolution and developmental biology we
know that each of us took a very smooth
Journey from being a pile of chemical
reactions in an oocyte in an
unfertilized oocyte all the way up to
being a human that's going to make
claims about second order cognition and
your true intelligence whatever else
you've got every step along the way was
nice and smooth it was very slow there
was never a lightning bolt that said
boom today you're you're a cognitive
being yesterday you were a you were a
pie you were just physics much like in
in evolution that never happened you can
all you can also start to roll back and
ask yourself whatever it is that you
think you have you know moral
culpability lady and whatever well how
about your ancestors of 200 000 years
ago did they have it well how about four
thousand a hundred thousand years ago
right well how about like there's never
a set of parents that were just you know
sort of whatever and then their
offspring bang The Offspring is now
cognitive right that never happened so
we have to we have to have this gradual
view of of intelligence and we have to
be able to recognize intelligence in
unconventional embodiments we're
terrible at that we're only good because
all our sense organs Point outward we're
only good at recognizing intelligence in
medium-sized objects moving at medium
speeds in three-dimensional space then
we're good we can see you know the
monkeys hiding the you know the thing of
waters and Ah that's that's pretty smart
and so okay but but if you had access to
your blood like like if you had in
if you had conscious awareness of the
the blood chemistry of your body at any
given point and you knew what your what
your liver was doing at any point in
time you would be able to recognize that
that organ as being very intelligent in
physiological space you would just be
able to that would be natural to you if
we had senses like that which we don't
so
um so so so I'm always interested in in
problem solving and intelligence and
weird unfamiliar spaces so now let's get
to the to the xenobot business
um much like
uh let's just warm up for a second with
it with this with this example um
imagine uh newts newts have uh these
these little kidney tubules that lead
that lead to their kidneys they are
normally made from eight to ten cells in
a if you take a cross section through
the through the tubule eight to ten
cells make this circle and inside
there's a lumen and that's your two bill
right what you can do is you can you can
make polyploid newts that have more and
more ends you know it's four and six and
eight and and as you do that the cell
size gets bigger and bigger so the first
thing that's already amazing is wait a
minute with with with extra copies of
all the genetic material and you still
make a normal nude that's wild but okay
that's one thing that the the the you
know uh the the software can make up for
like additional copies of every of every
piece of information that's amazing gets
better than that uh the nudes are the
same size so that means that fewer and
fewer cells have to be used to make the
same tubule because the cells are bigger
right so if you have something that's
made of you know 10 Legos and the Legos
are now bigger you have to use fewer of
them to get the same thing so that's
kind of amazing we're now this isn't
just response to injury or response to
environment your own parts are changing
and you can make up for that that's
amazing the most amazing part is that if
you make the cells truly gigantic such
that only one cell fits what happens is
one cell wraps around itself
leaving a lumen in the middle and you
get your you get your your normal size
Lumen with a completely different
molecular mechanism so instead of cell
to cell communication that builds a
normal tubule now you have some sort of
I don't know cytoskeletal bending that
that drags a single cell around in a
loop like that so what that tells you is
incredible problem solving on the part
of this collective intelligence despite
the changes in your very own Parts you
can call up different molecular
components
to serve the same large-scale anatomical
need it's a nice example of top-down
causation actually because it's the it's
the anatomy that drives the molecular
biology in this case
so
um so that's just an example of of of
cells you know it's kind of like uh I I
often in my in my own head I call it
play the hand you're dealt like whatever
you've got you're gonna figure out some
way of making the best of it right it's
it's an amazing capacity so we wanted to
ask a simple question uh about cells in
terms of their plasticity and in terms
of their um
ability to handle novelty and we said
this uh imagine this you look at an
embryo you look at the skin and you say
what do these skin cells naturally want
to do what do they naturally do and you
might say well they naturally want to be
this two-dimensional layer on the
outside of the animal and keep out the
bacteria it's pretty boring but that's
probably what they naturally want to do
well that's not what they naturally want
to do because if you take those cells
out of that context
and leave them on their own in a little
pile uh liberate them from the
instructive interactions with the from
the rest of the of the cells then you
get to find out what they actually want
to do when nobody's bullying them into
being the skin layer when what they
actually want to do is well they could
have done many things they could have
crawled apart from each other they could
have died as some cells do when they're
alone they could have um made a flat
monolayer like a cell culture instead
what they do is they come together they
form this little this little ball
and this by the way was all was all
joint work with um Josh bongard's lab uh
they formed this little ball uh the
little the the Cilia these these moving
hairs that they have on their surface
that you normally they're used to spread
the um the mucus down the the body of
the Frog they use those cells to row the
the Cilia they use them to row against
the water and that thing starts moving
around on its own so what what can they
do they can do mazes they can
um they can navigate all kinds of all
kinds of shapes they can uh regenerate
damage they can the the most amazing
thing they can do is um
if you if you if you sprinkle a bunch of
loose cells in their environment they
will go around and they will collect
those cells into little piles like like
bulldozers they'll sort of bulldoze them
into little piles guess what those piles
do those piles become the next
generation of xenobots they start
zipping around doing the exact same
thing and on and on it goes that's
kinematic self-replication right
um it's kind of Von Neumann's dream of a
machine that that builds itself out of
loose parts that it finds in the
environment so the amazing so so again
so here's what I think is amazing about
and there's all kinds of practical
applications of this that we can talk
about but but more interesting than that
I think
is this
there's never been selection to be a
good xenobi
where does the xenobot body plan and
behavior come from because normally when
you look at a creature and you ask why
is it a certain shape a certain color
why does it have behaviors it's easy you
say oh a selection because it had a
certain environment and everything that
didn't fit that environment is dead so
that's why it has it there's never been
the xenobots there's never been
selection to be a good xenobi why do
these cells know how to do this where
does that come from
so it's it's uh you know one of the one
of the things that that we've pushed is
this idea that this is a new Robotics
and Engineering platform not only does
it tell us something interesting about
the problem solving of these cells like
okay now you're in a different
environment you're missing all the other
cells that you're supposed to have you
can't reproduce in the normal froggy
fashion how are you going to do it they
figure out a new way to do it
um
so there's all that plasticity basal
cognitions all that but it's also a new
way of bioengineering because unlike
normal engineering where you're working
with passive materials where you have to
micromanage everything you have wood and
and copper and whatever else you have to
make sure that that whatever you want to
happen is going to happen this isn't
like that this is a an agential material
the the cells have agendas they know how
to do things and they want to do things
and the only way you're going to get
this material to do something different
is by providing appropriate input
stimuli rewards and punishments
incentives uh you know attractors
attraction molecules whatever you're
going to give them you're not
micromanaging it you're it's like it's
like um you know it's like building a
tower out of out of cats instead of
bricks it's a completely different
strategy right instead of instead of
putting them where you want that doesn't
work with cats you have to do rewards
and punishments so that you can you know
sort of train them to do these circus
tricks so uh that's you know we
we create the the first generation of
xenobots by manipulating the signals the
environment that that the cells get they
do the exact same thing to the Next
Generation the only reason this this
reproduction works is because they're
dealing with an agential material right
this wouldn't work with passive cells
nothing would happen it works because
the cells they're working with already
all all want to do this too
and I think the other powerful thing
about this is I think Evolution does
exactly the same thing I think evolution
is is mainly works by providing because
because the material that Evolution
works with is is is already in a gentle
material it's not starting from scratch
every single time so so what evolution
does is it searches the space of the
signals the rewards the whatever you
have to give these cells to get them to
do certain things like hey you're going
to be in a two-dimensional layer on the
outside of the okay tadpole so I think I
think it's an IT these these um these
xenobots
aside from all the Practical stuff they
provide a new window on on problem
solving on origin of body plans on
Evolution on uh on engineering on the
idea that you know Evolution maybe
doesn't build Solutions doesn't Discover
solutions to specific problems like
here's a frog to a yeah what does the
frog genome actually know well it knows
how to survive as a frog but apparently
it also knows how to be a xenobot who
knows what else it can do so right so so
Evolution makes problem-solving machines
it doesn't find specific Solutions
and that is interesting because it
doesn't sit really well with this
traditional picture of evolution as
blind and short-sighted the idea is
they're normally right Evolution's
supposed to always take the short-term
payoff and it's supposed to be blind and
whatever works now that's what it takes
if that's where true if that were true
why do we have these things that are so
good at solving scenarios that never
came up before it's almost you know it I
mean Engineers do this because they have
foresight right because you try to make
it a a you know an autonomous vehicle or
a robot or something that's going to
handle multiple things in the future
evolution is not really supposed to do
that so I think there are many you know
many deep questions here no for sure
like I I yeah I feel like we could talk
all nights about this and it's like
fascinating stuff and so like
yeah I guess
um I mean I had some questions about the
intelligence which you mentioned uh
prior to this but I guess we can stay
with the center box for now and like
yeah I mean I guess in theory then could
you do the same thing with human skin
cells and all different um potential uh
yeah tissue cells and then
um what are the kind of potential
applications I guess in Therapeutics but
beyond that as well with using this new
way of thinking
yeah yeah we're we're you know I can't
give any details because it's not
peer-reviewed yet and everything but but
I can we're definitely doing it with
other cell types it's not anything to do
with with amphibians it's not anything
to do with being an embryo it's a much
more it's a much more generic much more
generic phenomenon
um the applications uh come in a couple
of different flavors one set of
applications is useful synthetic living
machines so once we get better control
and and people people have already said
well why aren't you you know engineering
them and you can put synthetic biology
circuits in them and I was of course we
can and we're going to but the first
three and there's a couple more coming
the first few papers about this are all
Native because because I don't want to
this to be well well look you put some
kind of circuit in and now it does XYZ
and the point the point is look at what
these cells already know how to do with
a wild type genome right that's that's
the point and but but then of course
after that you program them so once you
start once you can once you can program
them with various
signals and stimul Eli and and maybe we
put in some some some circuits and
whatnot by electrics of course um then
you can imagine useful machines you
could imagine them uh you know they're
cleaning up the you know oceans they're
um uh searching for for rare maybe toxic
molecules they're doing sensing rescue
exploration uh micro sculpting organs
for transplantation you know Hydroponics
you can imagine a million different a
million different applications then you
can imagine applications in the body
right so so cleaning up arthritic knee
joints chasing down cancer cells or
bacteria in the gut you know fusing
retinas back to you know where they
belong all that kind of stuff down you
know someday someday in the future but I
think that that's only the first level
the second level is can we use these
Bots as a discovery platform to learn
the rules of morphogenesis you see one
of the things we're not very good at in
fact we're really bad at is
understanding the scaling of goals so
when you make a collective intelligence
system be it swarm robotics or a group
of cells or some kind of social or
financial structure whatever it is what
is the collective going to want
what are the goals of a collective
they're not linear functions of the
goals of the pieces that's for sure and
so we're not very good at predicting
those we're not giving good at
recognizing them we're not very good at
predicting them and we're not no good at
controlling them so can we use these
zenobots and those kind of platforms
as in a gentle material in which we can
practice this new science of
understanding the scaling of goals and
then and if you can do that then for
example in biomedicine you could if you
could if we get good at telling the
xenobot cells what to do in terms of
make a you know make a you know make a
little make a shape that looks like a
little house or something right just
religious generic control over growth
and form then we'll be able to do that
in Vivo for birth defects traumatic
injury aging degenerative disease cancer
and having nothing to do with the Bots
themselves we'll be able to control what
other cells build that that I think is
is kind of the next level of
applications and and then of course the
third level which is sort of you know
the most the most kind of philosophical
of all is is is to use them as a
platform to really dissolve a lot of our
um
you know a lot a lot of our binary
categories that don't really exist but
but we always thought they did because
of kind of failure of technology and
Imagination we thought that there was a
difference between machine and organism
right people say that every every year
somebody publishes a paper saying living
things are not machines and and and you
know and so they have these binary
categories that are that just did you
set up a bunch of pseudo problems that
uh are not compatible with the modern uh
capabilities of biology